j'accueille maintenant serge lama
ah oui
bonsoir bonsoir tabac donc noémie lenoir
oui oui un petit peu ces spécialistes
voilà voilà ils vont rappeler qui a fait
ma femme est une actrice oui oui voilà
serge lama dont le dernier cd s'appelle
feuille à feuille
donc c'est un album entièrement consacré
aux cabanis et serge lama
bon comment ça va bien alors après de
longues années dans le symphonique vous
prenez le contre pied de tout ce que
vous avez fait et vous faites de
l'acoustique du minimaliste là
subitement j'ai voulu faire quelque
chose de beaucoup plus dépouillée et on
est parti en tournée donc avec les
anciennes chansons dans un système
minimaliste et surtout sans son piano ma
vie a changé beaucoup maviepro musiciens
sans piano
c'est un public non non c'est pas le cas
c'est pas le cas il y avait beaucoup de
public et pas de piano j'étais l'océan
indien
l'auxerrois oui j'ai fait le sud de
l'océan indien coi là
la maman de noémie de la réunion voilà
pour ça que je dis ça oui l'île maurice
et le québec
j'ai fait six semaines au québec où et
isabelle boulay il
non j'aime ça je les parfaites mais en
fait j'ai fait attendre non non j'ai
fait une chanson pour elle mais non ça
c'est comme ça s'est arrêté là ouais
c'est pas comme laurent gerra avec
souligné mais oui alors les musiques ont
fait promo là un sérieux les musiques
donc il ya yves gilbert vous êtes avec
lui depuis soixante sépare vécu oui je
travaillais marley ou je vois là depuis
66 alors ensuite parmi les musiciens qui
ont proposé pour vous il ya christophe
leporatti nicolas manta zoo qui a
réalisé le disent d'ailleurs sylvaris
voilà sylvain michel québécois québécois
rrq et avec lequel j'avais créé une
chanson justement pour isabelle boulay
c'est pour ça que je connais sylvain
michel beaucoup plus que isabelle boulay
ouais encore que je collais belle
isabelle quand même mais pas à ce point
là non je veux sur la belle boulette
mais on est en jeu vous le direz vous
êtes bien vu au québec
oui je prêche mal vu au québec parce que
j'ai dit à une québécoise que son accent
je trouvais pas ça terrible je reçois
des lettres du québec
incroyable bah oui parce que c'est le
rempart sale con en général
mais sur un bel accent et québécois
simplement je comprends que aunis doit
pas être évident ouais parfois je peux
vous dire c'est très agréable d'être
avec une québécoise isabelle boulay se
dire étoile des québécoises personnel
genre et avec ou sans accent dakar alors
on va parler des paroles parce que vous
avez un problème ou qu'est le problème
inverse de julien clerc julien clerc on
parle toujours de ses paroliers on dit
toujours etienne roda-gil maurice vallet
jean loup dabadie et c'est bon et on
oublie toujours que je viens car il a
fait quand même toutes les mélodies de
toutes ses chansons calmes et l'onu
c'est énorme je n'ai clairement et vous
c'est un peu pareil serre que on oublie
souvent que vous avez fait toutes les
paroles de toutes vos chansons quand
même c'est peut-être aussi parce que je
fais partie de ces chanteurs qui ont de
la voix et qui occulte beaucoup ce
qu'ils chantent 1100t manière on écoute
le chanteur et puis on en fait c'est
depuis mes débuts effectivement j'ai
connu même si ce choix c'est vraiment
fort qu'on comprend pas bien et a
renvoyé en ahl a reproché un peu serré
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait ce disque
car maintenant avec trois musiciens on
comprend tout voilà en quoi la toupie je
joue un peu moins fort aussi voilà j'ai
fait un effort pour vous savez comment
on fait serge lama oui avec les petites
mains les mimines nommé lui montrez lui
tu adores ça tu as le droit
j'ai failli à feuilles donc voila et le
single s'appelle quand est ce qu on fait
l'amour à ses tocs écrit des paroles
donc dentelle quand est ce qu on fait
l'amour
on se plaît
d'ailleurs on se parlait de dieu
on se disait un jour
m
on se regarde et aubin
pour s'appuyer au tas
on s'est privé au beurre qui étranglait
no 15 qui tout fait
s'accrocher aux paroles maintenant oui
alors c'est pas c'est pas la plus
littéraire du disque il y en a d'autres
qui ne se jouera sur la fille il y en a
d'autres qui sont un peu plus littéraire
mais c'est voilà alors inspiration
toujours les femmes
oui enfin l'amour le couple les rapports
la nostalgie la nostalgie aussi comme
homme et comme tout le monde
à 18 ans vous aviez écrit une chanson
qui s'appelait quand j'avais 15 ans donc
c'est vraiment le roi de la nostalgie
parce qu'à 18 ans tu as une chanson qui
s'appelait quand j'avais 15 ans oui ceci
dit les beatles yesterday
il sait pas tellement vieux non plus et
je crois qu'on est nostalgique preto à
15 ans on va parler de vos 15 ans
justement
alors serge lama vous êtes né en 1943
oui vous êtes le fils unique de georges
et georgette chauvier on va parler de
votre père parce que le destin de votre
père vous a marqué et finalement à
décider du vôtre d'une certaine façon
totalement mais c'est vrai alors votre
grand-père lui déjà le père de votre
père n'était pas quelqu'un de très
gentil hein
non non non c'était quelqu'un qui était
très violent qui qui buvaient et qui
taper mon père avec la avec sa ceinture
qu'elle faisait malheureusement ça s'est
encore et ça se faisait beaucoup à les
paquets et mon père a été mis aux
enfants insisté il a eu une enfance
assez assez douloureuse mais c'est
difficile
alors votre père quitte aubusson avec sa
mère à l'âge de 5 ans ils vont à
bordeaux
et quand il a 15 ans il s'inscrit dans
une société qui s'appelle la girondine
et il rentre au conservatoire de
bordeaux il a grand prix et il peut pas
chanter sur scène pourquoi c'était 7 est
une douleur pour lui il ne passe que
normalement c'est comme au conservatoire
de paris quand on est comédien ont
généralement on jouait la comédie
française et puis normalement au théâtre
de bordeaux aujourd'hui jouer au grand
théâtre puis pour des raisons de
politique interne il n'a jamais pu le
faire et ça a été une de ses premières
blessures une de ses premières blessures
justement parce qu'on va voir y aura
beaucoup donc il fait pas de scène il a
pas d'imprésario alors un moment il se
dit je vais changer de nom parce que
c'est vrai que chauvier bon pas terrible
comme dans la pratique vous aussi vous
en avez changé la cause du prénom il
s'appelait georges j'aurais chauvier
georges chaulet serge chevalier c'est
pareil à rennes comme cibles des sites
de simplement georges gavarnie clavier
même il avait essayé et ses claviers
clavier georges clavier puis ça c'était
un élève non plus gavarnie gavarnie ça
ressemble un peu à guéthary donc il
s'est dit que ça va marcher
j'étais bof perce un bel homme oui très
beau et que selon les critères de
l'époque oui c'est un lois physiques à
la robert taylor
on appelait le prince charmant de la
chanson il décide de monter à paris vous
montez pas tout de suite vous restez un
an à bordeaux avec votre grand mère
et quand vous venez à paris c'est pas
drôle du tout vous retrouver tous dans
une petite chambre dans un meublé
et votre père votre mère votre grand
mère vous dans le 7e arrondissement rue
du vivier et votre père by fini au bout
d'un moment par décrocher un engagement
au delà des capucines
il ya il a joué aux capucines dans une
revue c'est là que j'ai connu mes
premières danseuses nues et s'il a
effectivement que j'ai connu aussi
nadine palier qui paraît c'est une amie
à nous elle était assise à n'est pas
longtemps madame de rothschild voilà
souvient grande copine mais drôle nadine
canadienne jouer sur scène nue avec le
père de serge lama est l'un des premiers
à voir les seins de nadine talent y est
voilà c'est vrai ça joue un peu comme ça
mais c'est une [ __ ] merveilleuse si
elle a doublé bardot dans certains films
non la poêle
il ya des films bardot c'est nadine kiki
type qui pose pour la poitrine et alors
c'est à cette époque que va naître votre
vocation parce que votre père qui êtes
aux capucines et en face à l'olympia et
un jour vous et 12 ans évite à votre
père moi un jour papa je serai en face
oui parce que tous les nouveaux tous les
plus grands ce commencé à passer à
l'olympia c'est les débuts de béco dont
on n'imagine pas aujourd'hui la carrière
un cas urgent hilbert c'était énorme
énorme à la casse et les premiers
fauteuils pour lui c'était d'ailleurs il
n'était même pas en vedette il était en
américaine de lucienne delyle je me
souviens bien de ça eddie constantine a
dit christine star immense et je voyais
ces noms briller sur ce fronton et et je
rêvais alors vous voulez donc allé à
l'olympia et c'est l'époque où vous
écrivez vos premières chansons vous êtes
fasciné parce que votre père écrivait
aussi il a été chanté par mariano bah
oui c'est là que le drame arrive votre
mère en fait c'est une île est au départ
un beau chanteur et moi et elle a eu de
cesse que de le faire arrêter comme ça
arrive assez souvent
alors que elle était très jalouse et
puis c'est terrible ce qu'on vivait dans
c'est quand même dans une toute petite
mon mari atteint chantelle meublé tous
les soirs j'entendais les engueulades
mois donc dans le livre un scellé les
scènes mais les scènes horribles qu'elle
lui faisait pas ce qu'il aurait pu
chanter mon père il a refusé des
tournées à cause de sa jalousie des
tournées de six mois par l prétexté que
c'était pas métier certain mais sûr que
pour pour manger tous les jours c'était
pas comme mes gamins pas que ça il
aurait pu vivre de son métier mais en
fait elle voulait pas quoi
kerry dans cette histoire c'est qu'elle
l'épousé parce que c'était un chanteur
et une fois qu'elle a été avec lui et
lui a interdit d'être chanteur pressé
bah oui c'est ça vous voulez le garder à
l esprit castratrice avec moi aussi à
l'essai par l'assemblée mais c'est en
même temps une femme elle m'aimait je
veux dire aller mais mon père mais c'est
de l'amour qui tue l'amour je ne devrait
pas retrouver cette époque là pour dire
la vérité parce que j'étais très
malheureux pendant dix ans je mange je
reprendrai tout voyez toute ma vie même
l'accident
mais cette période là je les reprendrai
mon pied alors à force de le tarauder le
pauvre il a décidé d'arrêter l'hiver 54
l'hiver terrible hiver de l'abbé pierre
ou il ya tellement froid
il vous annonce à tout ce qu'il a décidé
d'accepter l'offre d'un ancien patron du
théâtre des capucines qui s'appelait
paul borg a été reconvertie dans la
limonade et donc y voit là il vient
représentant bière sur ce type d'un seul
coup dit non à sa carrière et le dernier
soir c'était la bc il est la doublure de
guéthary était la fin de sa carrière à
l'arrêter doublure de 8 heures et le
lendemain matin ils partaient sur son
solex et sans maquillage
voilà royer toujours très bien arrangé
en tout qu'il était beau tout les
lumières il avait bouché avec sa
canadienne soir et puis malheureux quoi
bien sûr mais malheureux ils pleuraient
parfois oui il se confier à vous et vous
vous lui disiez écoute papa part il faut
que tu partes il faut que tu te casses
d'ici et ils vous répondez non je peux
pas y à toi oui et moi je lui dis c'est
pas une raison parce qu'on est beaucoup
plus humain plus malheureux quand on est
enfant et que les parents ne s'entendent
pas moi j'entendais des engueulades
permanente c'est pas mieux
j'aurais bonjour et partage qui j'aurai
tellement était heureux comme mon père
continue et serait même changé sûrement
ma propre vie et j'étais assez précoce
pour entendre ça et je me suis battu
mais il restait 1 quand même et ça fait
son malheur et une partie du mien dans
cette période là j'ai écrit là-dessus
des chansons un peu un peu il ya le
temps de la rengaine où je raconte cette
histoire qui est une des rares chansons
autobiographiques en pas réellement
autobiographique tienne d'autres
autobiographique
je m'en vais voir les petites femmes de
pillage été croisées mois
et voilà voilà l'histoire de serge lama
quand votre père prends la décision
d'arrêter vous prenez la décision d'y
arriver est peut-être je suis assez bien
sûr mais à quel prix c'est peut-être pas
il ya des prix à payer qui sont
peut-être pas très alors après ben voilà
donc après vous allez vivre toute la
famille dans un petit appartement issy
les moulineaux où ça va mieux évidemment
il a une vie plus régulière face à va
mieux c'est et puis c'est l'arrivée des
années les premiers crédits on peut
acheter la petite voiture et on partait
le dimanche 1 comme tout le monde l'a
sur les routes
allez manger le poulet dans dans l'herbe
avec les fourmis mais je détestais lui
pique nique avec les tables ans et getti
contraint de suivre
alors voilà et quand votre père c'est ça
la liane l'épilogué cette histoire quand
votre père à 60 ans il prend sa pré
retraite
vous faites un album avec lui qui
s'appelle la main père et fils et pour
vos vingt ans de carrière vous lui
offrez la scène du rex
c'est beau très très très beaux
souvenirs une tournée aussi une fait une
tournée d'une quarantaine de dates et
c'était un moment merveilleux on dirait
qu'on prévoit les choses sans le cac
iliad est assez vrai hein parce que mon
père est mort dans un accident de
voiture
neuf mois après oui en soit 184 pendant
napoléon avec ma mère aussi puisqu'ils
ont eu le même accident et ils sont
morts tous les deux et peut-être sans le
savoir je lui ai offert sa dernière
dernière grande joie oui c'est bien oui
et c'est je ne regrette pas cette amende
en lemay piste ya le rex cependant c'est
un moment j'ai un souvenir de ce rex
c'était on a fait trois jours c'était
merveilleux c'est peut-être le plus beau
souvenir que j'ai de music hall à paris
ouais les fantastiques par ces
instruments avaient un petit peu marqué
par les accidents il faut bien le dire
changer tout court maintenant
non mais c'est vrai au début de votre
carrière il ya l'accident très grave
enrico macias vous en a parlé d'ailleurs
avec son frère est décédé dans la
voiture jean claude massias
et puis il y avait aussi liane bénédicte
était votre grand amour week-end marqué
tout
c'était la pianiste delescluse la
pianiste électrique accompagner tous les
gens qui passent cabaret dont moi fin de
tous les plus grands des uns sont passés
là bas c'était une femme merveilleuse et
puis cet amour s'est arrêtée en plein
ciel pas au moment où c'était le plein
alors vous restez vous restez un an et
demi couchez vous réapprenez un marché
très difficilement c'est vrai qu'à 24
ans et c'est difficile de se remettre
d'un marché où on me donnait aucune
chance je pense que c'est mon métier qui
m'a sauvé peu à peu la vie reprend ses
droits à l'hosto vous rencontrez daisy
voilà donc comme quoi finalement un
tueur la santé que chez philippe voilà
et qu'ils se calment me suis raccroché
raccrocher à elle pour survivre lorsque
peut-être petit l'avais pas rencontrée
daisy je commençais à avoir du mal à
tenir moralement ouais et alors c'est
marrant enfin marrant c'est étonnant
c'est sur un brancard que vous
enregistrez votre premier succès les
ballons rouges